Salut, c’est Ludo de la chaîne Le Tatou. Aujourd’hui, je suis avec Brut
et on va partir à la rencontre d’une équipe de sportifs professionnels : les Soul Flyers.
C’est eux.
Et ça aussi, c’est eux.
Bref, vous l’aurez compris, les Soul Flyers sont des sportifs de l’extrême.
Alors, comment fonctionne leur discipline ? Comment s’entraînent-ils ?
Avec Brut, on vous emmène à la découverte d’un des sports qui semble être
les plus dangereux au monde : le vol en Wingsuit.
On est à Chambéry, à Savoie Parachutisme
et je vais rencontrer Fred et Vince, ils font partie des Soul Flyers,
c’est des BASE jumpers etparachutistes professionnels.
Là, on va faire du freestyle.
On a parlé du programme en gros mais on va laisser une bonne place à l’improvisation,
là, on va s’amuser.
Le Wingsuit permet donc de voler. Mais alors, comment ça fonctionne ?
C’est très simple, la combinaison est en fait constituée de trois parties :
les deux bras et les jambes.
Ces trois parties, au contact de l’air, vont se gonfler puis se rigidifier pour voler.
Il existe différentes tailles de Wingsuit en fonction du saut à effectuer :
soit à partir d’un avion, soit en BASE jump.
Plus la combinaison sera petite, plus elle sera maniable pour faire des figures par exemple.
Et plus elle est grande, plus elle sera facile à stabiliser,
utile dans le cadre d’un saut en BASE jump.
On utilise l’avion comme moyen d'entraînement,
on va aller s'entraîner sur certains "move" qu’on va aller faire d’avion
puisqu’on peut les répéter, on a beaucoup plus de temps.
Et puis une fois qu’on les a maîtrisés, on va aller les reproduire en BASE jump.
- Alors là, je vais essayer une combinaison de Wingsuit.
Pas sauter hein, juste l’essayer, vraiment. Et voilà, voir ce que ça donne.
- Donc là, tu l’enfiles là-dedans, dans le bras. Tu vas fermer tes cuissardes.
- Hop.
- Tu as une barrette de poitrine. - Ouais, nickel.
- Tu vas prendre ton pied là, comme ça et tu vas le rentrer dans le booster.
- Tu sens la petite semelle là ?  Il faut qu’elle soit bien à plat.
- Ouais je l’ai, ouais. Il faut qu’elle soit au fond, ouais.
- Tu tires en bas, tu zippes jusqu’en haut. - C’est lourd quand même !
- Et tu vas remonter, alors là, jusqu’en haut.
Écarte les jambes, voilà.
Tu peux faire des petites corrections avec ça en l’air
mais la plupart du pilotage, c’est avec les épaules et aussi le buste : cambrer, décambrer, les genoux.
Tu passes ta main derrière, tu viens attraper cette poignée. - Ah ouais d’accord et après, tu tires.
- Il faut casser sa vitesse avant de tirer parce que si t'es à pleine vitesse
et que la combinaison, elle est pressurisée à fond,
eh bien, quand tu vas vouloir aller derrière, ça va être tellement gonflé que tu vas avoir du mal.
Tu t’entraînes, ici, sur un centre de parachutisme, d’avion, à le faire plein de fois.
T’as pas le droit à l’erreur, tu dois tirer et c’est tout.
- Et de toute façon, t’as pas de déclencheur automatique, t’as rien du tout.
- Non, t’as pas de déclencheur automatique.
- Honnêtement je me sens… - Comme un poisson dans l’eau !
- Ou comme un écureuil en vol. Non mais ça donne envie de voler.
Ça donne envie, évidemment, de sauter et d’essayer quoi.
L’homme rêve depuis toujours de voler.
Les premières preuves de tentatives de vol datent du début du 20ème siècle.
En 1912, Reichelt s’inspire de la physionomie des chauves-souris pour créer un vêtement parachute.
Malheureusement, il est mort en testant son invention en sautant
du premier étage de la tour Eiffel, le 4 février de la même année.
Dans les années 30, Clem Sohn met au point une combinaison pour rallonger le temps de la chute libre.
Il décède le 25 avril 1937 à 26 ans, lors du festival aérien de Vincennes.
Son parachute ne s’est pas ouvert et il s’est écrasé devant les spectateurs.
C’est au début des années 1990 que le Français Patrick de Gayardon
reprend le concept de manière plus scientifique.
Il crée une combinaison aérodynamique, la pratique du vol en Wingsuit moderne est née.
Au début, on pliait des parachutes pour se faire de l’argent, pour se payer des sauts d'entraînement.
En progressant, on a réussi à rentrer en équipe de France.
Donc on a fait 10 ans de compétition en équipe de France. On a gagné 6 titres mondiaux.
- Ouais, j’ai vu ça. - Et pendant ces années-là,
pour vivre, parce que la compétition en parachutisme, ça rapporte pas,
même si t’es champion du monde, donc à côté de ça, on donnait des cours.
Quand on a arrêté la compet’, on avait plein d’idées et puis pas trop de moyens
et on voulait se lancer dans la réalisation d’images, dans des projets,
on avait des rêves et on voulait faire des trucs.
On faisait déjà du BASE jump en parallèle et on a voulu en faire de plus en plus
et se professionnaliser dans le BASE jump. Et puis, petit à petit,
on a réussi à gagner la confiance de certains sponsors qui nous ont permis de réaliser des projets, etc.
Et maintenant, ça fait 10 ans qu’on fait que ça.
- T’imagines, on va faire nos… Combien on a dit ? - On va fêter nos 20 ans, l’année prochaine.
20 ans de sauts ensemble. C’est fou quand même. - Ça fait 20 ans qu’on se connaît
mais l’année prochaine, ça va faire nos 20 ans de sauts ensemble.
Il est 8h du matin, je suis à côté de La Clusaz et j’attends Fred et Vince
qui vont faire un saut en BASE jump et combinaison Wingsuit depuis ce point là-haut.
- Salut ! Tu vas bien ? - Ouais super !
- Génial.
- Alors qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?  C’est quoi le programme ?
- L’idée, c’est de voler dans cette combe sur toute la partie en herbe qu’on voit là,
jusqu’à finir au niveau des cailloux qui sont là et puis ouvrir les parachutes
à côté de la ferme et se poser près des vaches.
- En gros, je vais devoir monter jusque là-bas et normalement, il vont me frôler.
- Je crois que donc, on est prêts pour y aller.
- L'ascension de la montagne, c’est parti.
Vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit là, juste avant le saut?
- On se sent plutôt bien. Le moment de la marche, c’est toujours sympa,
on discute un petit peu de la ligne de vol.
C’est un moment aussi de détente, où tu peux parler un petit peu de tout,
t’es en pleine nature, personne pour te déranger.
- Le vol, il s’adapte vraiment au terrain et au spot. Donc en fonction de la pente,
en fonction de comment les montagnes sont placées,
vraiment en fonction du terrain, on va prévoir le saut.
Sur des sauts comme ça, on a un plan et on le respecte.
- La météo , elle est importante dans ce sport? - La météo, elle est plus qu’importante.
- Elle est cruciale ? - Surtout quand tu fais des sauts en montagne.
Voilà, t'es encore plus tributaire de la météo.
C’est sûr que les prévisions, regarder un petit peu en avance ce qu’il va se passer,
ça nous aide beaucoup mais après, tu peux pas enlever le moment où
tu vas arriver sur place et tu vas pouvoir regarder et te dire : bon ok, c’est possible.
- Au-delà de la chute libre qui est déjà une sensation de dingue,
pouvoir maintenant planer dans des pentes, le long des reliefs, le long des falaises,
c’est dur à expliquer quoi. On peut regarder beaucoup de vidéos
mais c’est ce qu’on vit quand on le fait... - Ça doit être fou.
- C’est complètement fou et ça donne trop envie de recommencer.
- Est-ce qu'après 1500 sauts en BASE jump, même après ça, on a toujours peur ou pas quand on saute ?
- Ouais, y a toujours une peur, ouais, c'est sûr. - Une forme de peur, ouais.
- C’est pas naturel de se jeter d’une falaise. - Ouais, je suis d’accord !
- On est très concentrés avant le départ et la peur, ça permet de rester en vie.
Parce que le jour où on n'aura plus peur et où tu te rends pas compte du danger,
c’est là où t’es vraiment en danger, en fait.
Je viens d’arriver à mon spot, où je vais les attendre,
à peu près à la moitié du chemin pour eux, parce qu’ils vont passer à côté de moi en Wingsuit.
Et eux, ils sont tout là-bas... Tout là-bas, là-bas.
On est au top.
Et voilà, nous sommes arrivés.
Yes !
On ferme les visières ?
3, 2, 1...
Oh putain !
C’était génial de pouvoir les voir aussi près.
Ça faisait un moment qu’on avait cette idée-là en tête et qu’on voulait le faire
et ça a trop bien marché. On s’est régalés, une fois de plus.
Gavage !
Légère tremblotte... Je suis en redescente de la montée d’adrénaline.
- Vingt dieux !
- J’étais un peu moins bon que l’autre jour mais tu vois, quand même, ça passe large.
- On s’est laissé une demi-seconde d’écart... Je t’aurais laissé plus, je te rattrapais pas.
- C’est vraiment cool de pouvoir mettre des gens dans la pente et voler à côté.
Pour eux, ça fait un joli spectacle et pour nous, ça fait des points de référence
et du coup, c’est vraiment sympa.
- Ils sont passés tellement près ! C’est incroyable.
C’était hyper impressionnant. La vitesse et le bruit !
Je pensais pas que ça ferait autant de bruit en fait.
- Ouais, on est quand même à 150 km/h.
- C’est un sport qui est, c’est sûr, engagé, mais qui peut être fait en sécurité
si on respecte son briefing, si on respecte son entraînement,
si on respecte le spot sur lequel on va aller sauter par rapport à son niveau.
- Les gens en fait, ils voient l’étape finale. - Voilà ! Ils voient pas la préparation.
- Ils voient le truc, la vidéo sur Youtube avec un mec qui rase le sol : "Ouais, c’est des malades !"
Sauf que pour en arriver là… y a combien d’années de taf ?
- Il faut que le grand public puisse réussir un petit peu à distinguer un petit peu
de la masse d’information qu’il y a sur le web maintenant
des gens qui font n’importe quoi et puis ceux qui essaient de rester en vie
et puis, de montrer une image positive de notre sport.
On ne connaît pas exactement le nombre de personnes qui pratiquent le Wingsuit en France.
Le BASE jump et le Wingsuit sont des disciplines qui ne nécessitent pas
de licence à proprement parler.
N’importe qui peut, demain, s’il en a envie, acheter une voile et partir faire un saut.
Mais ces disciplines peuvent être très dangereuses. Il y a des accidents mortels chaque année.
Il est donc nécessaire d’avoir un entraînement acharné et des conseils
de professionnels pour pouvoir effectuer ça en toute sécurité.
- Euh... t'es prêt ? - Je pense.
- Tu stresses un peu toi ? - Grave !
C’est la première fois que je saute en parachute, c’est pas naturel de sauter d’un avion.
Le fait d’avoir Fred et Vince à mes côtés, ça me rassure beaucoup.
Après, ils m’ont avoué qu’ils pourraient rien faire s’il y a un problème...
Ce qui m’a beaucoup moins rassuré !
Petit décollage, au poil !
Ludo, énoooooorme !
C'était... alors vraiment, les gars, c’est l’une  des meilleures expériences que j’ai faites de ma vie.
- Énorme ! Énorme ! Bravo ! Bravo !
- Les gars... c'était le bonheur. - C'était super !
- Merci à vous, c'était dingue ! - Non mais, ta tête du début à la fin, le gros smile !
- Le smile ! C'était tellement génial !!! - "Wouaaaaaaaah !!!"
- C'était super ! - Génial, les sensations...
Je m’attendais vraiment pas à un truc aussi fou, quoi ! C'était énorme.
En plus on était en kiff tous ensemble... - Mais grave !
- On se donnait les mains... - On se checkait et tout.
- On se checkait, c'était énorme. - On n'a pas arrêté, c’était la grosse teuf.
- Je vais en refaire je pense, obligé, obligé, c'était génial. - Énorme ! On remonte ?
- Ouais, ouais. Mais ça donne qu’une envie, c’est de remonter.
Vous avez un sport de rêve, un sport de rêve... - Oh c’est super, ça fait plaisir de te voir comme ça.
- Tellement bon ! Ah ouais.
Ils ont le meilleur métier du monde parce que c’est leur passion,
le saut en parachute, le Wingsuit, le BASE jump...
C'est leur passion et ils arrivent à en vivre.
J’ai appris énormément de choses.
Déjà, il y a tout un truc autour de la sécurité dont on se doute pas forcément,
on pense que les mecs, ils arrivent, ils sautent, point. Eh bien pas du tout en fait!
Et c’est ça qu’il y a de fou, c’est ultra calculé tout ça, en fait.
C’est un sport à part entière, vraiment !